G
US APPRISED HOUR BY HOUR.
WE WILL CHECK BACK.
JOHN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, WE ARE
SEEING INCREDIBLE IMAGES OF A
WORLD WAR II U.S. NAVY DESTROYER
FOUND IN THE WORLD'S DEEPEST
SHIP WRECKED DIVE.
WE ARE TALKING MORE THAN 21,000
FEET UNDER THE PACIFIC.
CNN'S IVAN WATSON WITH THE
INCREDIBLE IMAGES.
>> THIS IS THE WORLD'S
DEEPEST-KNOWN SHIP WRECK,
LOCATED 6500 METERS BELOW THE
SURFACE OF THE PACIFIC.
THE NUMBERS 557 IDENTIFY IT AS
THE USS JOHNSTON, FILMED FOR THE
FIRST TIME UNDER WATER BY REMOTE
CONTROLLED SUBMERSIBLE.
THIS DESTROYER WAS ONE OF
SEVERAL U.S. NAVY SHIPS SUNK
BATTLING A VASTLY SUPERIOR
JAPANESE FLEET DURING A FURIOUS
BATTLE OFF THE COAST OF THE
PHILIPPINES DURING WORLD WAR II.
>> THEY USE EVERYTHING IN THE
BOOK TO STAY AFLOAT.
>> HOW DID YOU FEEL SEEING THE
I.D. NUMBERS OF THE USS
JOHNSTON?
>> IN A WAY, IT'S PAINFUL, BUT
IF ANOTHER WAY, IT'S
INSPIRATIONAL.
>> Reporter: FORMER U.S. NAVY
CAPTAIN CARL SCHUSTER SAYS HE
AND HIS FELLOW OFFICERS FOLLOWED
THE STORY OF THE JOHNSTON AND
ITS COMMANDER.
THE FIRST NAVAL OFFICER
POSTHUMOUSLY AWARDED THE MEDAL
OF HONOR.
>> HE MOVED WITHOUT ORDERS.
HE SAW AN IMMINENT DANGER TO THE
FLEET.
HE MOVED ON IT ON HIS OWN
AUTHORITY.
>> Reporter: EVANS BOUGHT TIME
BY ATTACK AC FLEET OF 23 JAP
NEEDS WARSHIPS.
>> HIS ACTIONS STARTED AND
CHARGED IF YOU WILL, BUT
ULTIMATELY SAVED SEVERAL
THOUSAND.
AMERICAN LIVES AT THE COST OF
HIS OWN AND MUCH OF HIS CREW.
>> Reporter: 186 CREW MEMBER,
INCLUDING COMMANDER EVANS, DIED
ABOARD THE JOHNSTON.
OVER THE PAST DECADE, SEVERAL
OUGHT WORLD WAR UI WRECKS HAVE
BEEN DISCOVERED IN THE PACIFIC
BY EXPEDITIONS BY THE LATE
MICROSOFT CO-FOUNDER PAUL ALLEN.
NAVYS TREAT THESE SITES AS
SACRED WAR GRAVES.
>> I SEE THEM AS THE TOOLS OF
CEMETERIES OF BRAVE MEN WHO DIED
FIGHTING FOR THEIR COUNTRY.
WHETHER THEY'RE GERMAN, JAPANESE
OR AMERICAN.
>> Reporter: THE MAPPING OF THE
USS JOHNSTON BRINGS SOME CLOSURE
FOR SURVIVING RELATIVES OF THE
SHIP'S CREW.
>> OUR GRATEFUL PEOPLE WILL
REMEMBER THE NAVY.
FOR UPDATES, THE USSO.
THE JOHNSTON.
THE SAMUEL B ROBERTS.
>> Reporter: BUT THE FINAL
RESTING PLACES OF THE THREE
OTHER SHIPS SUNK DURING THE SAME
DEADLY BATTLE HAVE YET TO BE
FOUND.
>> JOHN, THE OCEANIC, THE
PRIVATE COMPANY THAT BROUGHT US
THOSE AMAZING IMAGES IS NOT
SHARING THE EXACT LOCATION OF
THE USS JOHNSTON WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION BESIDES THE U.S.
NAVY.
AND THAT FITS A PATTERN OF OTHER
EXPEDITIONS THAT HAVE FOUND
THESE SUNKEN WARSHIPS FROM WORLD
WAR II.
THE REASON IS SAY THAT ARE
WORRIED ABOUT LOOTERS AND PEOPLE
TRYING TO DIG INTO THE WRECKS TO
TAKE AWAY SOUVENIRS OR EVEN TO
TAKE VALUABLE METAL AND SELL IT
LATER FOR SCRAP METAL THAT HAS
HAPPENED TO OTHER WORLD WAR II
SHIP WRECKS.
THEY WANT TO PRESERVE THE MEMORY
OF THIS WRECK AND WAR GRAVE.
>> EVEN AT 21,000 FEET?
THEY'RE GOING TO STEAL THE
SUPPLIES?
>> OKAY.
THAT ONE'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT.
BUT, CLEARLY, IT HAS HAPPENED IN
THE JAVA SEA, THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF WRECKS THERE, AMERICAN AS
WELL.
THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNS OF ENTIRE
SHIPS DISAPPEARING AND PROBABLY
SOLD FOR SCRAP METAL, WHICH IS
TRAGIC.
>> IT IS AN AMAZING STORY.
IVAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRICK US THO